this is the guatemalan beaded lizard  its bite can be deadly but we're a  larger threat to it than it is to us  there are less than 200 of these  creatures left in the wild making it one  of the most endangered lizards in the  world  their beaded black skin is adorned with  yellow spots and bands  they can be found mainly in deserts and  dry forests but even then they're hard  to find as they spend about 70 of their  lives underground  measuring up to a foot and a half when  fully grown they can pack a serious  punch  they are one of only two lizard species  that are venomous  the venom is in their saliva and it's  administered when they bite their prey  unfortunately this venom also strikes  fear among humans the biggest threat to  these otherwise docile creatures  hunting habitat loss and poaching have  forced this phantom lizard to fight for  its survival  this is the guatemalan beaded lizard